This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On January 7th, 1998, an envelope landed on the desk of Larry Calloway. He was a columnist with the Albuquerque Journal. It was sort of a combination of a press release and a ransom note and a photo. and a photo. The photo was a Polaroid of a cut-off riding boot with a huge Spanish spur, all in bronze. And I read the note. The note hinted that the bronze foot came from a statue
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1998年1月7日，拉里·卡洛维的桌上多了一个信封。他是《阿尔伯克基日报》的一位专栏作家。这东西有点像新闻稿、勒索信和照片的结合体。照片是一张宝丽来照片，拍的是一只砍断的马靴，上面带着巨大的西班牙马刺，全是青铜材质。我读了那张便条。便条暗示这个青铜脚来自一尊雕像
of a man named Juan de Oñate, seated on a horse. It was part of a monument on the side of a rural highway near where Oñate founded the first Spanish colony in New Mexico back in 1598. Larry figured this was probably a hoax. This is Stan Alcorn, a reporter with the investigative podcast Reveal. There are collaborators on the story today. So he handed the tip off to the newsroom, and a reporter called up the visitor center at the Oñate Monument. And asked, is your statue missing a right foot?
雕像刻画的是一个名叫胡安·德·奥纳特的人，他骑在一匹马上。这是新墨西哥州一条乡村公路旁的一座纪念碑的一部分，奥纳特就是在那附近于1598年建立了新墨西哥州第一个西班牙殖民地。拉里觉得这可能是一个恶作剧。我是斯坦·奥尔科恩，调查类播客《揭秘》的记者。我们今天是这个故事的合作者。于是他把这条线索交给了新闻部，一位记者打电话给奥纳特纪念碑游客中心。并问道，你们的雕像少了一只右脚吗？
And the guy said, what? And he went out and checked, came back, and he was, you know, in shock. He said, it's gone. Oñate is one of the world's lesser-known conquistadors, but his name is all over New Mexico. There are Oñate streets, Oñate schools. For decades,
那个人说，什么？然后他出去查看，回来后，你知道的，他震惊了。他说，不见了。奥纳特是世界上鲜为人知的征服者之一，但他的名字在新墨西哥州随处可见。有奥纳特街，奥纳特学校。几十年来
there was an annual fiesta where one lucky guy would get to be Oñate, complete with a cape and helmet. There's even a song. Viva Oñate! Viva! Viva Oñate! Viva! Viva la historia de este gran señor! There's even a song. In parts of New Mexico, he's treated as a kind of founding father.
这里每年都会举办一场节日，由一个幸运的人扮演奥纳特，身披斗篷，头戴头盔。甚至还有一首歌。奥纳特万岁！万岁！奥纳特万岁！万岁！伟大的先生的历史万岁！甚至还有一首歌。在新墨西哥州的部分地区，他被当作一种国父般的人物对待。
But history is not all song and dance and wearing capes. He was a conquistador after all. The envelope Larry got also included an excerpt from a history book on Oñate's treatment of New Mexico's native people. It described an incident that ended with Oñate sentencing a group of men from Acoma Pueblo to each have one foot chopped off. If the symbolism of removing the statue's foot was unclear, the note made it explicit. Clear, the note made it explicit. It said, we took the liberty of removing Oñate's right foot on behalf of our brothers and sisters at Acoma Pueblo. We will be melting this foot down and casting small medallions
但历史并不全是歌舞和穿斗篷。他毕竟是一个征服者。拉里收到的信封里还夹着一本历史书的节选，讲述了奥纳特对新墨西哥州原住民的残酷对待。其中描述了一起事件，结局是奥纳特判处阿科马普韦布洛的一群男子每人被砍掉一只脚。如果移除雕像脚部的象征意义还不明确的话，便条将其变得明确了。明确了，便条将其明确了。上面写着，我们擅自移除了奥纳特的右脚，以此代表我们阿科马普韦布洛的兄弟姐妹。我们将把这只脚熔化，铸成小型纪念章
to be sold to those who are historically ignorant. The statue's sculptor cast a new right foot and reattached it. The medallions never turned up, but the story stuck. It got picked up by NPR and the New York Times. I was a seventh grader in Albuquerque at the time, and what I remember is how the subject I found most boring, history, was suddenly this exciting mystery that remains unsolved to this day. Who stole Oñate's foot? And then there was the timing. 1998 was the 400th anniversary of Oñate's arrival. There were corto centenario celebrations planned all over the state. There would be theater, parades, a commemorative stamp. In a second note to the paper, these so-called friends of Acoma wrote,
卖给那些历史无知的人。雕像的雕塑家重新铸造了一只右脚并将其重新安上。这些纪念章从未出现过，但这个故事流传了下来。它被美国国家公共电台和《纽约时报》报道了。当时我是阿尔伯克基的一名七年级学生，我的记忆是，我曾经觉得最无聊的科目——历史，突然变成了一个至今未解的激动人心的谜团。是谁偷走了奥纳特的脚？然后还有时间的问题。1998年是奥纳特到达400周年。全州上下都计划举办四百周年庆典。将会有戏剧、游行、纪念邮票。在给报社的第二封便条中，这些所谓的阿科马之友写道，
We see no glory in celebrating Oñate's fourth centennial, and we do not want our faces rubbed in it. In other words, the point of cutting off the statue's foot was to spoil the party. And the centerpiece of that party, that got a mention in all the foot-cutting stories, was a cuarto centenario memorial being planned for Albuquerque's historic center. The proposal? Another bronze statue of Juan de Oñate. This one right in the middle of New Mexico's biggest city. But with all this new attention on Oñate,
我们认为庆祝奥纳特四百周年没有任何荣耀可言，我们也不想把我们的脸贴上去受辱。换句话说，砍掉雕像脚部的目的就是为了搅黄这场派对。而那场派对的核心，也就是在所有关于砍脚的故事中都被提及的，是一个计划在阿尔伯克基历史中心建造的四百周年纪念碑。这个提议呢？又是一尊胡安·德·奥纳特的青铜雕像。这座雕像就立在新墨西哥州最大城市的正中央。但随着人们对奥纳特的新关注，
the second statue wasn't going to get built without a fight. I still didn't see the storm that was coming. It was still in its infancy. Conchita Lucero was one of the organizers of the 400th anniversary celebrations in Albuquerque and one of the most passionate advocates for a new Oñate statue. A passion that goes back to her childhood, growing up in 1950s New Mexico, knowing almost nothing about Oñate, or the state's two centuries as a Spanish colony.
第二座雕像若想不经过一番斗争就建起来是不可能的。我当时还没有看到即将来临的风暴。它还处于萌芽阶段。孔奇塔·露西罗是阿尔伯克基400周年庆典的组织者之一，也是新奥纳特雕像最热情的倡导者之一。这种热情可以追溯到她的童年，她在20世纪50年代的新墨西哥州长大，对奥纳特或该州作为西班牙殖民地的两个世纪的历史几乎一无所知。
When I was a child, at 10 years of age, I asked my grandmother, who was a school teacher, I was reading the American history books, I said, didn't our people do anything? You know, that's how I felt. She didn't know New Mexico history. All Conchita knew was that her Spanish ancestors had come to the state centuries before the Anglo classmates who called people like her dirty Mexicans, or the Anglo teachers who kept her out of a leadership club. And she knew that racism and ignorance of history were somehow connected. If we make you feel like the underdog, and then we take away your history and take away your knowledge,
当我还是个孩子的时候，在10岁那年，我问我祖母，她是一名学校老师，我当时在读美国历史书，我说，我们的人民难道什么都没做吗？你知道的，我当时就是这种感觉。她不懂新墨西哥州的历史。孔奇塔唯一知道的是，她的西班牙祖先在比那些称呼她这样的人为肮脏墨西哥人的盎格鲁同班同学，或者把她排挤在领导俱乐部之外的盎格鲁老师早几个世纪就来到了这个州。她知道，种族主义和对历史的无知是以某种方式联系在一起的。如果我们让你觉得自己是弱者，然后我们剥夺了你的历史，剥夺了你的知识，
you're starting from scratch. Conversations, you don't know how to even participate. You just let the other guy put you down. Conchita thought if she could just search out her own European roots, it would help her fight back. None of this is uncommon in New Mexico, where people have been reaching back to their colonial roots and identifying as Spanish since the 1800s.
你就是从零开始。对话时，你甚至不知道该如何参与。你只能任由对方贬低你。孔奇塔认为，如果她能追寻自己的欧洲根源，就会有助于她进行反击。这在新墨西哥州并不罕见，自19世纪以来，人们一直在追溯他们的殖民根源，并将自己认同为西班牙人。
After Conchita retired, she found a lot of like minds in local genealogical and historical societies. She learned how to use birth and death and baptism records to trace her family tree. There was the occasional Native American ancestor, but she was most excited to find branches like the one that extended back to a Spanish captain who brought his wife and kids through the Chihuahuan Desert on Oñate's 1598 expedition. She saw them as having transformed the region by bringing livestock and Catholicism and the Spanish language.
孔奇塔退休后，在当地的家谱和历史协会里找到了许多志同道合的人。她学会了如何使用出生、死亡和洗礼记录来追溯她的家谱。偶尔也会有美洲原住民祖先，但她最兴奋的是找到了诸如这样的分支：可以追溯到一位西班牙船长，他在奥纳特1598年的远征中带着妻子和孩子穿过了奇瓦瓦沙漠。在她看来，他们通过带来牲畜、天主教和西班牙语，改变了这个地区。
You'd start finding your family members and you're going, wow, I never knew they did all of this. Did it change how you saw yourself? Yes. I never argued that one person wasn't as good as the other, but sometimes you were made to feel inferior. And at that point, that inferiority left. And so it was that Conchita was on the Cuarto Centenario committee when they met with the Albuquerque Arts Board
你会开始发现你的家庭成员，然后你会说，哇，我从来不知道他们做过这一切。这改变了你对自己的看法吗？是的。我从来没有争辩过一个人不如另个人好，但有时候你会感到自卑。而到了那个时候，这种卑微感消失了。因此，当孔奇塔与阿尔伯克基艺术委员会会面时，她成为了四百周年纪念委员会的成员
to discuss their request for a prominent new statue of Juan de Oñate, the man they called the father of the Hispanic culture and our state. And who the Friends of Acoma accused of destroying Native people's way of life. Was what happened at Acoma brought up? No. And was it on your mind? No. Was it something that you knew about?
讨论他们关于为胡安·德·奥纳特树立一座显眼新雕像的请求，这个被他们称为“西班牙文化之父”和“我们州之父”的人。而阿科马之友则指责他摧毁了原住民的生活方式。阿科马发生的事情被提出来了吗？没有。这在你的脑海里吗？没有。这是你知道的事情吗？
I wasn't as versed in it as I have become. For people who don't know Acoma, what is that? What is Acoma? This is Alida, or Tweedy Suazo, an Acoma woman who would become an outspoken opponent of an Oñate statue in Albuquerque. Acoma is the oldest continuously inhabited community in the United States. And it sits on a mesa 375 feet above the valley below. She actually carries a postcard of Acoma to show people when she travels.
我没有现在这么精通。对于不了解阿科马的人来说，那是什么？阿科马是什么？这位是阿莉达，或称特威迪·苏阿佐，她是一位阿科马女性，后来成为阿尔伯克基奥纳特雕像直言不讳的反对者。阿科马是美国最古老的持续有人居住的社区。它坐落在高出下方山谷375英尺的一座平顶山上。她旅行时甚至随身携带一张阿科马的明信片用来展示给别人看。
It's a village built on top of a mesa, which, if you're not from the desert, is like a huge rock pedestal. And that mesa just towers over the flat, empty plain below. All of it a hundred shades of brown, from light tan to deep rust. It's incredible. The tough thing with radio is you don't have pictures,
这是一个建在平顶山顶上的村庄，如果你不是来自沙漠，这就好比一个巨大的岩石基座。而那座平顶山高高耸立在下方平坦、空旷的平原之上。到处都是上百种棕色，从浅棕褐色到深铁锈色。这太不可思议了。做广播最难的一点是你们没有图片，
like how to help people visualize it, because it's like no other place on earth. No, it's not. It's beautiful. It's desert and rocks and sandstone, and that's where I come from, you know. And unlike the dozens of pueblos that disappeared after the arrival of the Spanish, Acoma is still here. Each year, tens of thousands of tourists drive an hour west of Albuquerque and then take a tour bus up a steep road to the top of the mesa. So just watch yourself. Don't get too close to the
比如不知道如何帮助人们想象它，因为它就像地球上的任何其他地方一样独特。不，它不是。它很美。这里有沙漠、岩石和砂岩，这就是我出身的地方，你知道的。与西班牙人到来后消失的数十个普韦布洛村庄不同，阿科马依然存在。每年，成千上万的游客驱车向西行驶一小时到达阿尔伯克基，然后乘坐旅游大巴沿着陡峭的公路开到平顶山顶。所以注意安全。不要靠
edge. If you happen to fall over the edge, this is the end of your tour and no repons will be given. So just keep that in mind. On top, you can see buildings made of mud and sandstone that tour guides say date back to the 1100s. If you think about it, these houses have been passed down through the same family for almost a thousand years now. So now we're going to be walking past some of the older houses right up here, folks. All along the tour, there are tables where Acoma artists sell their wares, mostly pottery. These pots are made from the clay from the area here, about two miles. But it's not just a tourist attraction. There are 15 families that live up top year-round,
边缘太近。如果你不小心从边缘掉下去了，这就是你旅程的终点，概不退款。所以请记住这一点。在山顶，你可以看到由泥土和砂岩建造的建筑物，导游说这些建筑可以追溯到12世纪。如果你仔细想想，这些房子已经在同一个家族中代代相传了近千年了。那么现在我们要走过一些较旧的房子的前面，就在这里，各位。一路上，都有桌子，阿科马艺术家在那里出售他们的商品，主要是陶器。这些罐子是用这里的粘土制成的，大约两英里远。但这不仅仅是一个旅游景点。有15个家庭全年住在山顶，
and hundreds more like Tweedie's, who go there for special occasions. Funerals, deaths, religious, fiestas, we were always there. deaths, religious, fiestas. We were always there. What did you know about the history of your people in that place? That we came from the underworld on the back of Grandmother Spider. We wandered the earth. And when we got to where Akuma was, we were told this is where we're supposed to be.
还有数百个像特威迪家那样的人，他们会在特殊场合去那里。葬礼、逝世、宗教节日，我们总是在那里。逝世、宗教节日。我们总是在那里。关于你们民族在那片土地上的历史，你知道些什么？我们是从地下世界乘着蜘蛛奶奶的背上来的。我们在大地上流浪。当我们到达阿科马所在的地方时，我们被告知这就是我们应该呆的地方。
That's what I knew, you know, that we've been there forever. Tweedy also knew that when the Spanish arrived, they did terrible things to her ancestors. But she didn't know the details. Historians know many of those details today because they were written down by the Spanish in letters and legal documents. These documents, to quote Oñate's best-known biographer, skim the surface of events and sometimes present Oñate, quote,
这就是我所知道的，你知道的，我们已经在那里永远地待下去了。特威迪还知道，当西班牙人到达时，他们对她的祖先做了可怕的事情。但她不知道细节。历史学家今天之所以知道许多这些细节，是因为它们被西班牙人写在了信件和法律文件中。用奥纳特最著名的传记作者的话说，这些文件只是浮光掠影地描述了事件，有时呈现出的奥纳特，引述如下
as he wished to be seen, not as things actually were. Which makes their description of what happened at Acoma all the more shocking. After 13 of Oñate's men came looking for food and were killed, Oñate declared a war of blood and fire. In the most brutal account of the battle that followed, Oñate's soldiers killed hundreds of men, women, and children, stabbed prisoners and threw them off the mesa, and set fires that suffocated women and children
如他希望被看到的那样，而不是事情的本来面目。这使得他们对阿科马事件的描述更加令人震惊。在奥纳特的13人寻找食物被杀后，奥纳特宣扬了一场血与火的战争。在关于随之而来的战役的最残酷的叙述中，奥纳特的士兵杀害了数百名男人、妇女和儿童，刺伤俘虏并把他们扔下平顶山，还放火窒息了那些在被称为基瓦的圣室中避难的妇女和儿童
who'd taken shelter in sacred rooms known as kivas. They then rounded up 500 prisoners and put them on trial. Oñate sentenced those over 12 years old to 20 years of slavery. Those under 12, he separated from their families, giving the girls to the church and the boys to the captain who'd just destroyed their village. And then there's the most infamous detail. In a document signed by Oñate himself, it says, His cruelty to the innocent of Acoma was one of the 12 crimes for which Oñate himself would later be tried and convicted by the Spanish crown.
他们随后围捕了500名俘虏并对他们进行审判。奥纳特判处12岁以上的人20年奴役。12岁以下的儿童则被与家人分离，女孩交给了教会，男孩交给了刚刚摧毁他们村庄的船长。然后是最臭名昭著的细节。在奥纳特亲自签署的一份文件中写道，他对阿科马无辜者的残忍行径是奥纳特后来被西班牙王室审判并定罪的12项罪名之一。
As punishment, he would be banished permanently from the territories of New Mexico. This is the history that Tweedy and I and many other New Mexicans were learning for the first time as news of the stolen foot ricocheted around the state. That was the beginning of it. That was everybody's first awareness. And at the same time, we were also learning that the city of Albuquerque was planning to build this new, much more prominent statue of Oñate. He had been cast out of New Mexico forever.
作为惩罚，他将被永久驱逐出新墨西哥州领土。随着偷脚事件的消息在全州回荡，特威迪、我和许多其他新墨西哥州人正是第一次了解到这段历史。那是这一切的开始。那是所有人的第一层认知。与此同时，我们也得知阿尔伯克基市正计划建造这座崭新的、更加显眼的奥纳特雕像。他已经被永远驱逐出新墨西哥州了。
And now you want to bring him back and put him on a statue? It's still mind-boggling. How Oñate went from a banished conquistador to a father of New Mexico that people wanted to put on a statue is a story for another podcast. But the simple answer is he was first. The first to build a European colony in the region, even if that colony was soon abandoned. He was among the first to bring wheat and sheep and Catholicism. And because every people needs a founding figure, Spanish New Mexico made Juan de Oñate its George Washington, even if he had been cast out forever. But it did not take long for the Albuquerque Arts Board to realize that Juan de Oñate was not everyone's idea of a founding father. They could see that another triumphant statue of him on a horse would be a bad look for the city. So by the time the foot was cut off of
现在你们想把他带回来并给他立一座雕像？这简直匪夷所思。奥纳特是如何从一个被驱逐的征服者变成人们想要为之树立雕像的新墨西哥之父的，这是另一个播客的故事。但简单的回答是他是第一个。第一个在该地区建立欧洲殖民地的人，尽管该殖民地很快就被废弃了。他是最早带来小麦、绵羊和天主教的人之一。由于每个人民都需要一个奠基人物，西班牙统治下的新墨西哥将胡安·德·奥纳特塑造成了他们的乔治·华盛顿，尽管他曾被永远驱逐。但阿尔伯克基艺术委员会没花多久就意识到，胡安·德·奥纳特并不是每个人心目中的国父。他们可以看出，另一尊他骑马的凯旋雕像对这座城市来说形象不佳。因此，当公路旁的
the old statue on the side of the highway, they made a few changes to the plan. The memorial would need to depict not just Oñate, but also the peaceful settlers who came with him and the Native Americans who preceded and survived him. And the exact form the memorial would take would be up to a team of artists. They had a team of two, but right before the newspapers got wind of the missing foot, they decided to add a third. When Nora Naranjo-Morse got the call, she was in the place where she's most comfortable, her studio. I mean, who would want to be here, right? In the studio with a fireplace in the rain. On the phone was the director of public art for the city of Albuquerque,
旧雕像的脚被砍掉时，他们对计划做了一些修改。这座纪念碑不仅要描绘奥纳特，还要描绘与他一起来的和平定居者以及在他之前和之后幸存下来的美洲原住民。而纪念碑的具体形式将由一个艺术家团队决定。他们原本是一个二人团队，但在报纸得知脚部失踪的消息前夕，他们决定增加第三个人。当诺拉·纳兰霍-莫尔斯接到电话时，她正在她最舒适的地方——她的工作室里。我是说，谁会想来这里，对吧？在下雨天有壁炉的工作室里。电话那头是阿尔伯克基市的公共艺术总监，
asking if she wanted to be part of a tricultural collaboration. It would be the Hispanic artist who had built the statue that had its foot stolen, an Anglo artist, and her, a Tewa Indian artist from the Santa Clara Pueblo. The call was so out of the blue. This was a public art project. I'd never done public art, really. This was with other people. I had been working solo, so I didn't really know. I was listening. And did you say yes right then, or do you remember how the phone called? I said yes. I said yes right away because I opened my mouth and I said yes. And then afterwards I thought, oh, I wonder what this is going to be like.
问她是否想参加一个三元文化的合作。这将包括那个雕像被偷走脚的西班牙裔艺术家、一位盎格鲁艺术家，以及她——来自圣克拉拉普韦布洛的特瓦印第安艺术家。这个电话来得太突然了。这是一个公共艺术项目。我其实从来没做过公共艺术。这是和其他人一起合作。我以前一直是独立创作，所以我其实并不知道。我在听。你当时就答应了吗？还是你还记得这个电话是怎么打的？我答应了。我马上就答应了，因为我一张嘴就说了“好”。然后事后我想，哦，不知道这会是什么样的。
She'd find out when she showed up for that first meeting. In an institutional room with fluorescent lighting and a chalkboard, the other artists wheeled in a model of a statue they'd already put together. It was another triumphant statue of Juan de Oñate on a horse. And that's when they begin to talk about the granite pedestal and how I could use it. The pedestal beneath Oñate's horse's feet. Right.
当她出席第一次会议时，她就会知道了。在一个有着荧光灯和黑板的机构房间里，其他艺术家推来了一个他们已经拼凑好的雕像模型。那是另一尊骑在马上的胡安·德·奥纳特凯旋雕像。就在那时，他们开始谈论花岗岩基座以及我该如何使用它。奥纳特马蹄底下的基座。对。
I felt insulted. I felt insulted. I felt hurt. I felt marginalized. I didn't think I could do that. Although in myself, I was thinking that there was a solution, that art could tell a story that was truthful. Nora quite literally refused to put Oñate on a pedestal, and the artist went back to the drawing board.
我觉得受到了侮辱。我觉得受到侮辱。我觉得受伤了。我觉得被边缘化了。我觉得我做不到这一点。尽管我内心深处在想，其实有解决办法，艺术可以讲述一个真实的故事。诺拉字面意义上拒绝把奥纳特放在基座上，艺术家们只好重新回到图纸前。
But now Nora was in the public eye, and soon she started getting calls from other Pueblo people who wanted her to leave the project entirely in protest. I didn't do that. And when I refused, I got some, I think people were disappointed. But I realized that by me staying in the game, I would at least be able to fight for that voice that I think was so important. Not just my artistic voice, but the voice of these people that had gone through this incredible experience that changed their culture completely. And I kept going back to those things. And I kept going back to those things.
但现在诺拉暴露在公众视线中，不久她就开始接到其他普韦布洛人的电话，他们希望她为了抗议而完全退出这个项目。我没有那样做。当我拒绝时，我得到了一些——我认为人们很失望。但我意识到，只要我留在局里，我至少能够为那个我认为非常重要的声音争取权益。不仅仅是我的艺术之声，还有那些经历了彻底改变他们文化的不可思议经历的人们的声音。我一直回到这些事情上来。我一直回到这些事情上来。
The year of the 400th anniversary, 1998, came and went, and there was still no plan for the memorial. But the city would not give up. All the attention had made the memorial a very public test of whether the state was the land of tricultural harmony that it claimed to be. And so every time the process hit an impasse, the city just threw more time and money at it, hiring mediators and forming committees. At one point, one of those committees came up with a plan that would have restarted the whole artistic process, a plan Conchita's side couldn't tolerate. It called for a memorial without Oñate.
400周年纪念年，即1998年，转瞬即逝，纪念碑依然没有计划。但这座城市并没有放弃。所有的关注使这座纪念碑成为了一个非常公开的考验，检验该州是否真的是它所宣称的三元文化和谐之地。因此，每当进程陷入僵局时，这座城市就会投入更多的时间和金钱，聘请调解员并组建委员会。有一次，其中一个委员会提出了一项计划，该计划将重新启动整个艺术创作过程，这是孔奇塔一方无法容忍的计划。它呼吁建造一个没有奥纳特的纪念碑。
And would focus on coexistence of Hispanics and the indigenous. Well, then we said it wasn't our celebration. You know, it's your celebration now. It's not ours. You know, you don't get invited to a wedding. You don't start telling the bride and the groom, you should have had it this way or that way. And that's what it was. It was our celebration. But it was your celebration with public money in a public space that's in a city that has people of all different backgrounds. The grant was for our celebration, not for the Acoma celebration or for anybody else's. As far as Conchita's group was concerned, the presence of Oñate was non-negotiable. our celebration, not for the Akama celebration or for anybody else's. As far as Conchita's group was concerned, the presence of Oñate was non-negotiable,
并且将重点放在西班牙裔和原住民的共存上。好吧，然后我们说这不是我们的庆典。你知道的，现在这是你们的庆典。不是我们的。你知道的，你没有被邀请参加婚礼。你不能开始对新郎新娘说，你们应该这样办或者那样办。事实就是这样。这是我们的庆典。但这是你们用公共资金在公共空间里举办的庆典，而这座城市拥有各种不同背景的人。这笔补助金是为了我们的庆典，而不是为了阿科马的庆典，也不是为了其他任何人的庆典。在孔奇塔的团队看来，奥纳特的存在是不可商量的。我们的庆典，不是为了阿科马的庆典，也不是为了其他任何人的庆典。在孔奇塔的团队看来，奥纳特的存在是不可商量的，
which made it hard to negotiate. In the end, there simply was no single design that everyone could agree on. In fact, eventually the artists stopped talking to each other. Instead, they proposed a memorial made up of two separate artworks, a series of bronze statues of Spanish settlers, including Oñate in full armor, and Nora's response, an abstract land art installation made out of the desert itself. It had gone from a small bronze statue to a memorial that would take up most of a city block and cost over half a million dollars, requiring the city to issue special bonds. Now the question was, would the city approve it? Conchita and the pro-Oñate forces lobbied the city council, while Oñate opponents, like Tweedy, took their case to the people. You know, finding out, well, who's for us and who isn't? And how do we target the people in that area
这使得谈判变得困难。最后，根本没有一个所有人都能达成一致的单一设计。事实上，最终艺术家们停止了彼此交谈。相反，他们提出了一座由两件独立艺术品组成的纪念碑，一组西班牙定居者的青铜雕像，其中包括身穿全套盔甲的奥纳特，以及诺拉的回应——一个由沙漠本身构成的抽象大地艺术装置。它已经从一个小型青铜雕像变成了一个将占据城市大部分街区、耗资超过五十万美元并需要该市发行特殊债券的纪念碑。现在的问题是，市政府会批准它吗？孔奇塔和支持奥纳特的力量游说市议会，而像特威迪这样的反对奥纳特的人则把他们的诉求带给了民众。你知道的，弄清楚，好吧，谁支持我们，谁不支持？我们如何锁定该地区的民众
for them to call their councilmen? That's the first time I'd ever done that, you know? You were like becoming an activist for the first time? Yeah, I was. I'd never done that. The statue, and also a highway the city was trying to build through a national monument of ancient petroglyphs, was making first-time activists out of a lot of Pueblo people. It's the first time that we really rallied around something.
让他们给市议员打电话？那是我第一次做那样的事，你知道吗？你就像是第一次成为一名激进分子？是的，我是。我以前从没做过。这座雕像，以及城市试图在古岩画国家纪念碑中修建的一条公路，让许多普韦布洛人第一次成为了激进分子。这是我们第一次真正围绕某事团结起来。
Activists, artists, citizens, and city councilors were headed for a final showdown. down. This is GOV 14, and now from Government Center in downtown Albuquerque, the Albuquerque City Council. In a series of meetings, the City Council auditorium was divided, like a pep rally, or Congress. On one side was the pro-Oñate crowd, mostly Hispanic people around Conchita's age. On the other side was the anti-Oñate group. They tended to be younger and more diverse, Native Americans, but also Anglos and African Americans, and a lot of people who identified as Chicano or Mestizo, explicitly embracing their indigenous as well as European ancestry. The city council tried to give the two sides equal time to speak. And in hour after hour of
激进分子、艺术家、市民和市议员们正走向最后的对决。这里是GOV 14，现在从阿尔伯克基市中心的政府中心为您播报阿尔伯克基市议会。在一系列会议中，市议会的礼堂分裂了，就像一场动员大会或国会一样。一边是支持奥纳特的群体，大多是孔奇塔这个年龄段的西班牙裔人。另一边是反对奥纳特的群体。他们往往更年轻、更多元化，有美洲原住民，也有盎格鲁人和非裔美国人，还有许多自称奇卡诺或麦士蒂索人的人，他们明确拥抱自己的原住民和欧洲血统。市议会试图给双方平等的发言时间。在长达数小时的
public comment, they went back and forth, but not over the design of the memorial really. They were fighting over something much bigger and much more personal, their place in American history. Our colony was the first in what is today the United States of America. You can't pretend that we didn't come here 400 years ago. This is really a matter of denigrating the Hispanic people of New Mexico. Do I have to stop? Oh, no, no, no. Have some courage and listen. First of all, soy Chicano.
公众发言中，他们来回辩论，但实际上并不是在争论纪念碑的设计。他们在争论一个更大、更私人的问题，他们在美国历史上的地位。我们的殖民地是当今美洲合众国境内的第一个。你们不能假装我们没有在400年前来到这里。这实际上是一个贬低新墨西哥州西班牙裔人的问题。我是不是得停下来？哦，不，不，不。拿点勇气出来听听。首先，我是奇卡诺人。
And unlike some Hispanics that are here in the audience, I didn't just get off the plane from Spain. Oñata does not represent the best of my culture. You are not representing me. And I just want to say that I'm sorry that you and a small group of Hispanics in this room feel like they have to slam another people's culture in order to
不像观众席里的一些西班牙裔人，我不是刚下飞机从西班牙来的。奥纳特并不代表我文化的最好一面。你不能代表我。我只想说，我很遗憾你和这个房间里的一小群西班牙裔人觉得为了
feel pride. There were dozens of speakers, but the leaders were women from Acoma, like Tweedy. I didn't know that the awful things that happened to my people happened to my people until this statue became an issue. I'm really tired of being used as tourists and our wares are the only things that matter in this community. in this community. I'm begging you, don't do this to my people. I'm begging you, don't do this to my people. Don't hurt them this way. It's not right. Thank you very much.
感到自豪就必须贬低另一个民族的文化。发言者有数十人，但领导者是来自阿科马的女性，比如特威迪。直到这座雕像成为一个问题之前，我根本不知道发生在我族人身上的那些可怕事情。我真的厌倦了被当作游客利用，而且我们的商品是这个社区唯一重要的东西。在这个社区里。我求求你们，不要这样对待我的族人。我求求你们，不要这样对待我的族人。不要这样伤害他们。这不对。非常感谢。
Last speaker, Ayal Sanchez-Davis. It seemed like most people were on Tweedy's side. But if the city voted against the memorial, it wouldn't just be saying no to this statue of Oñate and the settlers, and to Nora's landscape art. It would be admitting that this whole very public process that had dragged on for more than two years had been a failure. The committees, the design iterations, the debate, all for nothing. So when it finally came time to vote, all those in favor please signify by saying aye.
最后一位发言者，阿亚尔·桑切斯-戴维斯。似乎大多数人都站在特威迪这一边。但如果市议会投票反对这座纪念碑，那就不仅仅是对这座奥纳特和定居者的雕像以及诺拉的大地艺术说不。这也是在承认这个拖延了两年多的备受瞩目的整个过程是一场失败。委员会、设计迭代、辩论，全都白费了。所以当最终到了投票表决的时候，所有赞成的人请说“赞成”以示表态。
Aye. Those opposed? No. They voted seven to two to build the memorial. That motion passes. They voted 7-2 to build the memorial. That motion passes. After the vote, Conchita Lucero told a reporter, I think our kids will finally learn about their ancestors. Tweedy Suazo and other anti-Oñate activists formed a prayer circle in the city council chambers and wept. We worked so hard. And it just, it didn't matter. It didn't matter what wept. We worked so hard and it just it just is it didn't matter it didn't matter what we said
赞成。反对的人？反对。他们以七票对二票通过了建造纪念碑的决议。该动议通过。他们以7比2的投票结果决定建造这座纪念碑。该动议获得通过。投票结束后，孔奇塔·露西罗对一名记者说，我认为我们的孩子终于会了解他们的祖先了。特威迪·苏阿佐和其他反对奥纳特的激进分子在市议会大厅里围成一个祈祷圈并失声痛哭。我们工作得那么辛苦。结果却，这毫无意义。这毫无意义，哭泣着。我们工作得那么辛苦，而它，它就是，这毫无意义，我们所说的话毫无意义
it didn't matter what we do it didn't matter that we educated it just didn't matter. If it all happened again today do you think it would happen the same way or what would be different? I think Pueblos are just a little bit more politically astute now. Tweedy thinks what they learned was that the right arguments aren't enough. You need the right decision makers. She's one of several anti-Oñate activists who went on to get involved in electoral politics. She's now the chair of the Native American Democratic Caucus of New Mexico. And this last cycle, she helped raise money and get out the
我们所做的事情毫无意义，我们受过的教育毫无意义，这真的毫无意义。如果这一切今天重新发生，你认为还会以同样的方式发生，还是会有什么不同？我认为普韦布洛人在政治上现在更加精明了。特威迪认为，他们学到的是，正确的论点是不够的。你需要正确的决策者。她是几位后来参与到选举政治中的反奥纳特激进分子之一。她现在是新墨西哥州美洲原住民民主党核心小组的主席。在最近的这次选举周期中，她帮助筹集资金并为德布·哈兰德拉票，后者是刚刚当选进入国会的两名美洲原住民女性之一。今天，如果你去参观芬兰纪念碑，你看到的不会是骑在马上的奥纳特。这是一个妥协。它实际上是将两个纪念碑挤在了一起。第一个纪念碑甚至不用下车就能看懂。那是两多打真人大小的青铜雕像，男女老少，还有牛和羊，艰难地爬上一座小山。
vote for Deb Haaland, one of the two Native American women who just became the first ever to be elected to Congress. Today, if you go visit the Finnish memorial, what you'll see isn't Oñate on a horse. It's a compromise. It's really two memorials crammed into one. The first you can grasp without even getting out of your car. It's more than two dozen life-sized bronze figures, men and women, oxen and sheep, trudging up a hill.
胡安·德·奥纳特在最前面。步行前往，没有刻有他名字的牌匾，并且在一台可能对准他的脚也可能没有对准的安全摄像头的警惕注视下。第二个纪念碑就在它旁边，从空中俯瞰就像一个巨大的泥土螺旋。但从地面看，你真的必须亲身体验它。它与那种咄咄逼人、具有说教意味并宣称“这就是我的意思”的艺术形成了鲜明的对比。我认为这反映了普韦布洛人的思维方式。它要微妙得多。它不像我们作为文明人、被殖民者所习惯的那样去清晰表达。
Juan de Oñate is in front. On foot, no plaque with his name, and under the watchful eye of a security camera that may or may not be pointed at his feet. The second memorial, right next to it, looks from above like a huge dirt spiral. But from ground level, you really just have to experience it. It's a striking contrast to the kind of art that that's really in your face and didactic and says, this is what I mean. I think that reflects Pueblo thinking. It's much more subtle. It doesn't articulate in the way we've become used to as, you know, civilized people, colonized people.
当我见到诺拉·纳兰霍-莫尔斯去参观时，她刚刚清理完留在纪念碑她那一部分里面的垃圾。当我们沿着一条缓缓螺旋向下通往地面的泥路行走时，她手里拿着一个甜甜圈包装纸。街道在我们右边和左边的沙枣树和杜松灌木的土堤后面消失了，然后是建筑物，然后是奥纳特本人，直到最后，在螺旋的中心，你所能看到的只有土地和在岩石上流淌的溪水。
When I met Nora Naranjo-Morse to get a tour, she'd just been picking up trash left inside her part of the memorial. She was holding a donut wrapper as we walked down a dirt path that spirals slowly downhill into the ground. The street disappears behind the berms of chemisas and junipers on our right and left, then the buildings, then Oñate himself, until finally, at the center of the spiral, all you can see is the land and water trickling across a rock.
我非常喜欢这样，因为我认为很久以前就是这样的。这就是我对过去的诠释。如果你蹲得很低，你几乎可以瞥见奥纳特到达之前的世界。这是一个逃离。但它也是为了在两种完全不同的世界观之间制造一种对抗。因为当你走出螺旋……这就是你看到的。
And I like that very much because I think that's what it was like a long time ago. That's how I interpret the past. If you sit low to the ground, you can almost get a glimpse of a world before Oñate arrived. It's an escape. But it's also intended as a confrontation between two totally different worldviews. Because as you walk back out of the spiral... This is what you see.
电话线，奥纳特来到这里的雕塑，朝北看着，红绿灯，全都在那里。所以你看到，在某些方面，当他们到来时，他们给我们带来了巨大的机遇，但代价却如此高昂。残酷的殖民化对我们产生了永远的影响。我认为我们永远不应该忘记这一点。她希望纪念碑的这部分能提醒人们这一点。但说实话，来这里的人并不多。这座纪念碑并没有吸引像当年围绕纪念碑的冲突那样多的关注。我认为这就是为什么重要的管理不仅在于捡垃圾，还在于让那个故事保持生机。
The telephone lines, the sculpture of Oñate coming here, looking north, the stoplight, it's all there. And so you see that in some ways when they came, they brought us great opportunity, but at such a high cost. The brutal colonization was forever affecting to us. And I think we should never forget that. She hopes her piece of the memorial will remind people of that. But honestly, not that many people come here. The memorial doesn't attract nearly as much attention as the conflict over the memorial did. I think that's why it's important stewardship, not only to pick up the trash, but also to keep that story alive.
因为将会有更多代人来到这里，想知道，这是什么？我们的故事本该到此结束，直到去年，一个古老的谜团再次浮出水面。还记得我们告诉你的第一座雕像吗，就是那个被偷走一只脚的那座？近二十年来，偷脚贼一直隐匿在暗处，身份不明。然后有一天，导演了《烟雾信号》和《剥皮人》、可能是最著名的美洲原住民电影制作人的克里斯·埃尔
Because there are going to be a lot more generations of people coming, wondering, what is this? And that's where our story was going to end, until last year, when an old mystery re-emerged. Remember that first statue we told you about, the one that got its foot stolen? Well, for almost two decades, the foot thieves had remained in the shadows, their identities unknown. And then one day, Chris Eyre, the director of Smoke Signals and Skins, possibly the best-known Native American filmmaker,
正在圣菲一家很棒的墨西哥新墨西哥餐厅La Choza吃饭。我和合伙人正坐在那里吃塔可，有人走过来对我说，我边吃塔可边有个故事要告诉你。我说，哦，该死，又来一个故事。然后，你知道的，我听到了一些关键词，但我并没有那么专心听。突然间我明白了。我说，等等。我转过身说，你是在说我想的那件事吗？那个人就是砍下第一座奥纳特雕像脚的那个人。
was at La Choza, this great little New Mexican restaurant in Santa Fe. I was sitting there eating a taco with my business partner, and someone came up to me and said, I have a story to tell you as I'm eating my taco. And I said, oh shit, not another story. And, you know, I heard a few key words, but I wasn't listening that intently. And all of a sudden it dawned on me. I said, wait a minute. And I turned and I said, are you talking about what I think you're talking about? It was the guy who cut the foot off the first Oñate statue.
或者至少他声称自己是那个干这事的团伙的发言人。事实的真相是，除了最终我相信了之外，我永远无法证实这一点。克里斯相信了这个人，部分原因是他看到了一个非常坚实的证据。当克里斯第二次在松树林里见到他时，他打开了一块黑色天鹅绒，露出了一个20年来谁也没见过的人。谁也没见过。看啊，那里出现了大概28英寸长、带有绿锈的西班牙征服者青铜马靴。我对自己说，哇。然后我环顾四周，对自己说，我到底在哪里，我在这里到底在干什么
Or at least he claimed to be a spokesman for the group who did the deed. And the truth of the matter is that I could never verify it other than I believed it in the end. Chris believed the guy, in part because he was presented with a very solid piece of evidence. When Chris met him for a second time in a forest of piñon trees, he unwrapped a piece of black velvet to reveal something no one had seen for 20 years. one had seen for 20 years. Lo and behold, there appeared probably a 28-inch long bronze patinaed boot of a Spanish conquistador. And I said to myself, wow. Then I looked around and I said to myself, where the hell am I and what the hell am I doing here
脚上有几个地方被削掉了一小块，那是他们半心半意地试图兑现给历史盲制作纪念章的承诺，但除此之外它仍然完好无损，并且依然有吸引人们注意力的力量。如果克里斯知道偷脚贼的身份，他并没有透露。但他确实谈到了他们的动机。你知道的，涉案当事人并不是从激进分子的立场出发说话的，也不觉得自己是个激进分子。这个人觉得自己像个历史学家。他不是想发起一场运动或影响政策，只是想把奥纳特在1599年对阿科马男子所做的事
a few chunks of the foot had been shaved off where they'd made a half-hearted attempt to follow through on those medallions for the historically ignorant but otherwise it was still intact and still had the power to grab people's attention if Chris knows the identity of the foot thieves he is not revealing. But he did talk about their motivations. You know, the party involved is not speaking from an activist position and doesn't feel like an activist. This person feels like a historian. He wasn't trying to start a movement or affect policy, just to write what Oñate did to Acoma men in 1599
写进新墨西哥州殖民化的历史中。那个故事至今还没有一座雕像，也许永远也不会有。但与此同时，阿科马之友紧紧抓着奥纳特的脚不放。如今新闻里的绝大多数雕像都是邦联雕像。我们要采访一位专门研究这些纪念碑是如何获得资金资助的记者。
into the history of the colonization of New Mexico. That story still doesn't have a statue, and maybe it never will. But in the meantime, the friends of Acoma are holding on to Oñate's foot. Most statues in the news these days are Confederate ones. We're going to talk to a journalist who's researched exactly how those monuments are funded.
广告之后马上回来。我们本周关于奥纳特的报道是与《揭秘》合作完成的，如果你还不是它的粉丝，这是一个来自调查报道中心和PRX的播客。本周末《揭秘》实际上还将播出另一个引人入胜的雕塑故事。它将于周六播出，我们希望你们能订阅并收听完整内容。所以我们将与其中一位涉事记者交谈，为您提供一点预览。这个故事聚焦于邦联纪念碑，由调查基金会的赛斯·弗里德韦斯勒和布赖恩·帕尔默报道。对布赖恩来说，他对邦联纪念碑的兴趣
That's coming up after this. Our story about Oñate this week was a collaboration with Reveal, which, if you're not already a fan, is a podcast from the Center for Investigative Reporting and PRX. And Reveal is actually airing another fascinating statue story this coming weekend. It comes out on Saturday, and we want you to subscribe and listen to the whole thing. So we're going to talk with one of the reporters involved to give you a little preview. The story focuses on Confederate monuments, and it was reported by Seth Friedwessler and Brian Palmer of the Investigative Fund. And for Brian, his interest in Confederate monuments
全都始于一个历史悠久的公墓。他去拜访了他曾祖父母安葬的地方。他们都曾是奴隶，后来自我解放逃到了北方。布赖恩的曾祖父在内战期间曾在美国陆军服役，他们埋葬的公墓位于弗吉尼亚州的一个军事基地里。那里有一个白人区和一个黑人区。我所看到的，一方面是悲惨的，另一方面是启迪人心的。悲惨的部分是，这个非裔美国人公墓不像基地对面那座白人公墓那样得到精心照料。所以对我来说这有点震撼。在白人公墓里，有一个墓地特别吸引我的眼球。
all started in a historic cemetery. He was visiting the place where his great-grandparents were buried. They were both enslaved and then self-emancipated to the north. Brian's great-grandfather served in the United States Army during the Civil War, and the cemetery where they're buried is located in Virginia on a military base. There's a white section and a black section. And what I saw was, on the one hand, tragic, and on the other hand, enlightening. The tragic part was that this African-American cemetery was not as well tended as the white cemetery across the base. So that to me was a little bit striking. At the white cemetery, there was one grave in particular that caught my eye.
它的周围插着几面邦联旗帜。这个木制十字架上的铭文，一个小牌匾上写着“致未知的邦联士兵”。所以我想，哇，这真的很有趣。这座白人公墓得到了维护。黑人公墓，他们至少扫过落叶，但它已经坍塌了，看起来根本没有得到任何管理。所以我开始纳闷，为什么这样的公墓，黑人公墓，历史悠久的黑人公墓，为什么这样的公墓会处于如此糟糕的状态？为什么邦联墓地、纪念碑和遗址的状态会如此之好。所以作为记者，显而易见的事情
It had a couple of Confederate flags around it. And the inscription on this wooden cross, a little plaque said to the unknown Confederate soldier. So I thought, wow, that's really interesting. This white cemetery is being maintained. The black cemetery, they at least raked, but it was tumbled down and it just did not look like it had had any stewardship. So I started wondering, well, why are such cemeteries, black cemeteries, historic black cemeteries, why are cemeteries such as this in such terrible shape? And why are Confederate cemeteries and monuments and sites in such wonderful shape. So the obvious journalist
要做的那就是顺着资金去找。所以你会注意到护理上存在差异，这让你意识到护理上的差异反映在资金的差异上，这笔钱被花在了邦联纪念碑上，却没有花在献给非裔美国人经历和非裔美国人历史的纪念碑上。然后你开始追查这些资金。这些资金不仅被用于邦联纪念碑的保护和维护，还被用于专门用于宣传
thing to do then is to follow the money. So you notice that there's a disparity in the care, and it makes you realize that that disparity in care is reflected in disparity of dollars, and that money is being spent on Confederate monuments and not being spent on the monuments devoted to the African-American experience and the African-American history. And then you start chasing down the dollars. And not only are those dollars being used for the preservation and the maintenance of Confederate monuments, they are being used for Confederate monuments devoted to this
失落之因叙事的邦联纪念碑。那么你能为不了解它的人描述一下什么是失落之因叙事吗？是的，所以你做了这个重要的区分。我们考察了一系列讲述内战历史的遗址。有战场，有各种不同地方的故居，他们在墙上展示的是
lost cause narrative. So could you describe what the lost cause narrative is to people who don't know it? Yes, so you make that important distinction. We looked at a range of sites that tell Civil War history. You have battlefields, you have homes in all sorts of different places, and what they put on the walls
“迷失之因”叙事。那么，您能否为不太了解的人描述一下什么是“迷失之因”叙事呢？是的，您做出了这个重要的区分。我们考察了一系列讲述内战历史的遗址。有战场，有各种不同地方的故居，以及他们挂在墙上的东西
and what their guides say is factual. This happened here, this unit fought. That to us is history. That's acceptable. That is educational. That's perfect. What we did was we focused on sites where the historical interpretation and what the people there say and what is omitted represents an ideology, not an evidence-based comprehensive approach to the Civil War, but what represents ideology, what perpetuates ideology. So, for example, ones that either minimize or deny the centrality, the importance of slavery in the Civil War, the ones that pump out these to democracy and to our society, and I think it's led us to where we are now politically, in fact. So these monuments that you were investigating, they didn't appear right after the Civil War. So could you talk about when they showed up and what political purpose they were serving when they were erected? When they showed up and what political purpose they were serving when they were erected?
导游所说的是事实。这里发生过战斗，这支部队参战了。对我们来说这就是历史。这是可以接受的。这是具有教育意义的。这很完美。我们所做的是，我们将重点放在那些历史解释、当地人的说法以及遗漏的内容反映出一种意识形态的地方，而不是基于证据的、关于内战的全面方法，而是反映意识形态、延续意识形态的地方。例如，那些淡化或否认内战中奴隶制的核心地位、重要性的地方，那些向民主和我们的社会灌输这些思想的地方，事实上，我认为这导致了我们现在的政治处境。所以你们调查的这些纪念碑，它们并不是在内战结束后立即出现的。那么，你能谈谈它们是什么时候出现的，以及它们在竖立时起到了什么政治作用吗？它们是什么时候出现的，以及它们在竖立时起到了什么政治作用吗？
They didn't just spring up after the Civil War, largely because the South didn't have the money to erect them. Our first major monument here in Virginia was donated by Brits. Thomas Stonewall Jackson was put on the lawn of our capital, and that was funded by British folks. But monument building really had three main phases at the tail end of the 19th century, the beginning of the 20th century, and then right around the time of civil rights. So interesting, huh? It's not coincidental. these things, they came about over time in these moments of white people in power, really, literally exhibiting their dominance through these statues and monuments. And what I think is really interesting, you make this really good point in the piece, is that the current discussion or controversy over historic monuments, this isn't current PC culture kind of thing. There was objections all the way along. It's just people didn't listen because they were mainly objections by African-Americans. There is a history of African-American resistance to
它们并不是在内战结束后自然涌现出来的，主要是因为南方没有资金来建造它们。我们在弗吉尼亚州的第一座大型纪念碑是由英国人捐赠的。托马斯·杰克逊（Thomas Stonewall Jackson）石像被放置在我们议会的大草坪上，那是英国人资助的。但是纪念碑的建造在19世纪末、20世纪初以及民权运动前后经历了三个主要阶段。很有趣，对吧？这不是巧合。这些东西随着时间的推移而出现，在白人当权的这些时刻，他们实际上、字面意义上通过这些雕像和纪念碑展现了他们的统治地位。我认为非常有趣的是，你在文章中提出了一个很好的观点，即当前关于历史纪念碑的讨论或争议，并不是什么当下的政治正确（PC）文化。反对声音一直存在。只是人们没有听取，因为这些反对意见主要来自非裔美国人。非裔美国人一直有着抵抗
this sort of self-glorification of white elites. Frederick Douglass wrote about monuments, W.E.B. Du Bois wrote about the monuments, and they were saying, you know, this is just ridiculous. And yet, because blacks didn't have the political power to do anything, and because the so-called mainstream media controlled by white men did not write about these objections, it could find no traction in larger culture. So people now in the 21st century can, with ignorance, tell us, well, you never objected before. No, it's that you never paid attention before, and we never had the tools to make you pay attention in the same way that you forced us to pay attention to your
这种白人精英自我美化的历史。弗雷德里克·道格拉斯（Frederick Douglass）写过关于纪念碑的文章，W.E.B. 杜波依斯（W.E.B. Du Bois）也写过关于纪念碑的文章，他们当时就说，你知道的，这太荒谬了。然而，由于黑人没有政治权力去做任何事情，而且由白人男性控制的所谓主流媒体没有报道这些反对意见，它无法在更大的文化圈中获得支持。因此，21世纪的人们现在可以无知地告诉我们，你们以前从来没有反对过。不，事实是你们以前从来没有关注过，而且我们过去也没有工具让你们关注，就像你们通过将你们的
myths and your stories by embedding them in public space. So you began investigating these lost cause memorials. How did you go about investigating how public funds were used to maintain and promote these sort of ahistoric sites? So how do we go about this? First, we had to differentiate between the sites that were doing real, honest, genuine historic work and those that were promoting ideology. So we did a lot of our searching on the web first, and we talked to people in the places where these monuments and sites were.
神话和故事嵌入公共空间，迫使我们关注它们一样。所以你们开始调查这些“迷失的因由”（Lost Cause）纪念馆。你们是如何着手调查公共资金是如何被用来维护和推广这类反历史遗址的呢？那么我们是如何着手的呢？首先，我们必须区分那些正在做真实、诚实、真正的历史工作的遗址，以及那些在宣传意识形态的遗址。因此，我们在网上做了大量的搜索，并与这些纪念碑和遗址所在地的人们进行了交谈。
And then we went so we could go to the museum, so we could go to the gift shop, so we could talk to the docents. So we visited 50, 60 different places and we lost count. And then once we figured out which sites we wanted to focus on, we filed dozens of open records and Freedom of Information Act requests to local and state governments and to the federal government to find out where this money was coming from. We looked at IRS documents. We looked at state budgets line by line by line. So that was our methodology. And so could you tell me just like you're going around to these sites with your collaborator, Seth Fried-Wesler, and Seth is white, correct? Seth is white. I am not. I am African-American.
然后我们去了那里，这样我们可以去博物馆，去礼品店，和讲解员交谈。所以我们参观了50、60个不同的地方，多得数不清。一旦我们弄清楚了我们想把重点放在哪些遗址上，我们就向地方政府、州政府和联邦政府提交了数十份公开记录和《信息自由法》请求，以查明这些资金的来源。我们查阅了国税局（IRS）的文件。我们逐行、逐行、逐行地查阅了州预算。这就是我们的方法论。那么，你能告诉我，当你和你的合作者塞思·弗里德-韦斯勒（Seth Fried-Wesler）一起去这些地方时，塞思是白人，对吧？塞思是白人。我不是。我是非裔美国人。
Yes. Were you ever separated in such a way that you were given a different experience of these sites? So that's a very interesting question because we tended to report separately. I knew based on my reporting with other white colleagues and with my wife who's white that we would be treated differently. So the stuff that Seth heard and the stuff that I heard, very different. And I think that's part of the story, but it's also the frame of the story. We went to some of the same places like the Confederate section of Oakwood Cemetery here. I spent a lot of time there. Seth visited. What people told him was alarming. What people
是的。你们是否曾被分开对待，以至于你们对这些遗址有了不同的体验？这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为我们往往是分开报道的。根据我与白人同事以及我那身为白人的妻子的报道经验，我知道我们会受到不同的对待。所以塞思听到的话和我听到的话非常不同。我认为这是报道的一部分，但它也是报道的框架。我们去了一些相同的地方，比如这里奥克伍德公墓（Oakwood Cemetery）的邦联墓区。我在那里呆了很长时间。塞思去参观过。人们对他说的话令人震惊。人们
told me was supposed to be reassuring. They needed to get the PR engine going for the visiting black person. But for a white person, they could be themselves, as it were. They could let their prejudiced hair hang down. And that, to me, was telling. There are people who just don't know the other part of this history, the African American strands that have been purposely erased. But then there are people who do know, and still they trot out these myths, either to preserve their power, to make themselves feel better, whatever it is. That's a kind of intellectual dishonesty that I think is really, really dangerous. And I think that's—we're trying to eliminate the gray area that people can wallow around in when they say, well, you know, this is, you know, heritage, and they've been standing for 100 years. And if
对我说的话本该是让人安心的。他们需要为来访的黑人启动公关机器。但对于白人，他们可以做回自己，可以说，他们可以无拘无束地暴露出他们的偏见。对当时的吉姆·克劳（Jim Crow）来说，这说明了问题。有些人根本不知道这段历史的另一部分，那些被故意抹去的非裔美国人的线索。但也有人知道，他们仍然抛出这些神话，无论是为了维护自己的权力，还是为了让自己感觉更好，无论出于什么原因。我认为这是一种非常非常危险的知识不诚实。我认为这就是——我们正试图消除人们在说“这你知道的，这是传统，它们已经矗立了100年”时可以随波逐流的灰色地带。如果
the black people want their own monuments, then they should go build them. Well, a lot of these monuments were built with public funds. Yes, there were private donations, certainly, but land was donated, infrastructure was built, and money allocations came from general assemblies, city councils, county supervisors. So don't tell me that we should accept sites and statues that were erected in a violent and anti-democratic atmosphere when African Americans were being lynched. African Americans could not participate in the political process that put these things up. Now that we can, we're supposed to shut up? that we can? We're supposed to shut up? We have no time for fake history. And this is fake history. We funding for Confederate monuments, subscribe to Reveal. There is amazing and jaw-dropping tape in the story from some of their visits to memorials
黑人想要他们自己的纪念碑，那他们就自己去建。好吧，其中许多纪念碑是用公共资金建造的。是的，当然有私人捐款，但土地是捐赠的，基础设施是建成的，资金拨款来自议会、市议会、县主管。所以不要告诉我，我们应该接受那些在暴力和反民主氛围中、在非裔美国人被 lynched（私刑处死）时竖立的遗址和雕像。非裔美国人当时无法参与建立这些东西的政治过程。现在我们可以了，我们本该闭嘴吗？我们有权这么做？我们本该闭嘴吗？我们没时间理会虚假历史。这就是虚假历史。我们寻找南方邦联纪念碑资金的资助，请订阅《Reveal》。节目中包含一些令人惊叹、瞠目结舌的录音，记录了他们对纪念馆的访问
like Beauvoir, which is Jefferson Davis' home and presidential library in Biloxi, Mississippi. And Brian and Seth also do the important work of chasing down how much public money, taxpayer money, our money, is being spent to maintain these sites. Check it out at revealnews.org or wherever you listen to podcasts. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Stan Alcorn and edited by Delaney Hall. Mix and tech production by Sharif Youssef. Music by Sean Rial. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team is Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Joe Rosenberg, Taryn Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks to Reveal from the Center for Investigative Reporting and PRX, our collaborators on the story this week.
比如杰斐逊·戴维斯在密西西比州比洛克的故居兼总统图书馆博瓦尔（Beauvoir）。布莱恩和塞思还做了重要工作，追查了多少公共资金、纳税人的钱、我们的钱，被花在维护这些遗址上。请访问 revealnews.org 或在任何你听播客的地方查看。本周的《99%无形》（99% Invisible）由斯坦·阿尔康（Stan Alcorn）制作，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）剪辑。混音和技术制作由谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Youssef）完成。音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。我们的资深制作人是凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。库尔特·科尔stad（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括艾弗里·特勒夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、塔伦·马扎（Taryn Mazza），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。特别感谢来自调查报道中心和 PRX 的《Reveal》，他们是我们本周故事的合作者。
Thanks also to Roman Garcia at KUNM and the filmmaker Chris Ayer. He interviewed the alleged foot thieves for his film that is currently seeking funding. So you should seek him out and give him some. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还要感谢 KUNM 的罗曼·加西亚（Roman Garcia）和电影制作人克里斯·艾尔（Chris Ayer）。他为他的电影采访了涉嫌盗窃脚模的人，该电影目前正在寻找资金。所以你应该去找他并给他一些资助。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心广播街（Radio Row）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。